[Laughter]
keys over here
i don't have keys but there is no i got
this it's weird
what are you doing aaron hello what are
you doing hello
i'm just i'm just moving a thing through
a line like in a carnival game
okay i [ __ ] it up mm-hmm gonna do it
again i got uh i because i succeeded
okay great and no
i'm gonna get you just kidding no you're
not okay cool bye
okay okay
i'm gonna go on cam you talking
yeah talking anyway bye
alrighty
and details then we don't have
bargaining chips oh my gosh
look at all of this security number look
moana
shawn me and bug snacks are all
confirmed
okay just say jayden no no listen the
information is out we need to share with
you what information is that we need to
oh
[Laughter]
well i don't know what happened i just
walked
so we got we got some confirms uh guys
you want to share
oh yes yes it's pretty epic
so purple dark green and light blue
we're also
it's no big deal
[Music]
are all confirmed i sat there and
watched i didn't have med base gang but
i saw them all do it and confirm
together i'm green i'm three foot six
ninety two pounds hit me up so aaron
and i we were blowing asteroids he
killed my high score
destroyed me i got 20. he got like 30.
he was nuts no i didn't i got 20. that's
only how many there are he's 20. never
mind
i've only got two i'm trying to build
you up here you know
thanks for loaning me a million dollars
oh yeah
i was doing water stuff yeah
um i was doing water stuff yeah
she wasn't singing her don't kill me
song as she ran around you weren't even
near
true oh that's so true you should have
been around us for a year
then wait is that still talking because
i still don't hear him at all
i don't hear dan dan you want to click
crew link and then hit control and r
oh thank you damn computer um
all i'm saying is that everyone had
someone with them except dodger
i don't know that that's another oh my
god
let's get them it does say dumb on me
what did you do i didn't do it but it
does say something with you oh there he
is
so i was with you guys justin i was in
that
dumb does that stand for didn't you
murder
[Laughter]
yeah because i'm accusing somebody else
of murder no it's due murder as in d.u
murder murder
damn ulterior motives
get him out of here did unfortunately
murder
[Laughter]
wow did uh damn
so sorry dodger if it's not you i'm
apologizing
yeah right about that fine being blocked
all the lights i'm gonna do my card oh
gosh
oh boy oh this room is as black as my
soul
[Laughter]
you know me i'm gonna take slightly well
me oh
oh my god are you serious i'm laggy i'm
not doing it again okay okay
[Music]
i do want to do this
and then we could do
uh maybe well i would like to do
oh god i'm gonna finish my tasks i was
gonna be done
uh i went up to o2 by the tree hacker
was there too
uh but she was down below but there was
aaron's body under the tree
uh hacker how long were you in there
was in that area uh because we fixed the
lights i thought mock dude
mark no we were fixing the light i think
mock was the one who actually fixed the
lights
and then everyone kind of dissipated
i know it was it was a bit of a disaster
it happened so who was on the left
so i was coming down kind of everyone
had left security and i saw
uh aaron's body under the tree hacker
was in there as well
uh i heard you just didn't see the body
or
how sorry hacker how long were you in
there not long at all
like i said as long as it takes for me
to go to the water bottle and try to
fill
it up wait jaden did that body happen as
you checked
uh it was dead when i saw it when i
checked vitals wait you saw a buddy as
well
no i was on fire oh you were in vitals
oh okay so this was like
more than four or five seconds ago
okay so it happened when you checked
vitals no it happened it already was
dead
oh okay it already was dead okay it's
interesting mock what you've been up to
i'm pretty alana and mark i know whoa
don't get me on this because i was one
task away from getting everything done
before i die and that's never happened
i literally opened the panel i'm like
yes yes and then body reported so
i don't really know what's happening in
the wider world but i've avoided
everybody
to everyone who was on lights who went
where
afterwards i promise you that hacker saw
me
you walked left and down i walked up and
right and went straight over to mad bay
i'm currently in the tunnel heading to
specimen right now
where was mark are you in the doorway i
was uh
i after lights i went straight down to
that little electrical coil thing and
then i went
up to the the panel this is the round
where we all cleared each other on med
bay
hacksaw is clear on med bay yeah i'm not
suspicious of factory
self-reporting no i'm not no i'm not
suspicious of hacker at all because at
the beginning that's why i'm saying how
long was she ending
i see it could have been a self-report
as well yeah i think but actually no
because it was already dead for a while
[Music]
anything i'm no closer to understanding
i'm going to finish my
screen
i got calms hey okay he glitched
oh no what happened my friends the door
closed
okay i'm going home did you do your
tasks mock
i'm
yeah we
so
that was lovely that that double kill
was beautiful
oh my god oh well